so the film rewinds itself and replays
again and again more rioting in an
american city on sunday night this time
back in minneapolis ground zero the
place where our groundhog's day
nightmare began a year ago and a
possible preview of the rioting that
will probably happen
when the derek chovin trial concludes no
matter how it concludes blm militants
smashed police cars assaulted police
officers vandalized police stations
looted local businesses video footage
shows
the pillagers ransacking shoe stores
auto parts
retailers pharmacies dollar stores even
pizza restaurants a little caesars they
rioted stole some packages of dough i
guess i don't know why
as we've learned in recent months no
ointment can
numb the pain of systemic racism quite
like an armful of stolen merchandise
at least that's what we're supposed to
believe now the thing that caused
the latest round of rioting is as always
the depravity and moral degeneracy of
the writers themselves
that's really what causes it but the
ostensible excuse the cover
for the chaos is the death of a man
named dante wright
who was shot and killed by brooklyn
center police during a traffic stop
earlier in the afternoon brooklyn center
is a
town i think to the north of minneapolis
nearby
not many details are currently available
about this incident and as of yet the
body cam footage
has not been released the details don't
matter anyway right they never do blm
has its narrative which is always the
same narrative
and is adjusted only to include the few
sketchy and superficial details
that get imprinted immediately onto the
public
conscious right in this case
the detail is that wright was pulled
over allegedly
for an air freshener now to hear people
on twitter tell it
uh and i have and i have seen it phrased
exactly this way
wright was shot by the cops for having
an air freshener
they pulled him out of the car executed
him on the spot
for the air freshener but really because
they're racist
this is the narrative doesn't matter if
it's true or not
and incidentally it is almost certainly
not true as any rational person would
immediately suspect
doesn't mean the shooting was justified
but any person with a brain knows when
they hear that story
there's got to be more to it right based
on the few seemingly reliable details
that had been provided
wright was initially pulled over for a
traffic violation maybe it was the
air freshener it doesn't really matter
but then it was discovered
that he had an outstanding warrant
officers
officers tried to apprehend him but he
ran back to his vehicle
he was shot at some point during that
process he drove away
and crashed shortly after as journalist
andy noe reports
wright had previously posted many
pictures on social media of himself
flashing gang signs using drugs and so
on
now none of this makes the shooting
justified
but it does point to there being more to
the story than just an innocent guy with
an air freshener
there's always more to the story of
course
it's possible that the shooting was
still unjustified that he was murdered
that it's all as bad or nearly as bad as
blm says it is
but if that's the case it will be by
mere happenstance
blm will automatically claim that every
shooting of a black man
by police is a racist execution
perhaps one of these days they'll
accidentally be right
i mean they haven't been right even once
so far about everything
when you take any individual incident
all the things that blm says about that
incident they've never been right about
all of those things
and in terms of of the most basic claim
of a cop shooting a black man because of
racism
they have literally never been right
about that
that has never turned out to be true not
once
maybe this will be the one occasion
where they're right i doubt whether
this is such an occasion but um i'll
wait for time and evidence to tell the
whole story
whatever really happened with dante
wright what we can say for sure is that
the average blm or antifa radical out in
the streets
protesting doesn't care what really
happened with dante wright
even less do they care about police
brutality or fascism
least of all do they feel any actual
pain over the loss of life
the anger is performance the tears are
for show
because this is all one big stage play
when they're out in the street
crying because of dante wright i don't
believe the tears and you shouldn't
either
the only thing that's real is the
physical destruction they cause
everything else is fake now if that
seems like a harsh assessment
consider the fact that between january
1st 2020
and march 31 2021 over these past 15 or
16 months
when rioting over alleged police
brutality has been so on trend
there have been 507 white people shot to
death by police
compared to 271 black people and yet
somehow
nobody knows the name of any of those
white people save one ashley babbitt
she was an unarmed woman shot in the
neck and killed by capitol police on
january 6th
we know her name not because blm rallied
to her cause
but because they so conspicuously
refused to rally to her cause
indeed her death was more likely to be
celebrated by the very people
who'd spent the previous year pretending
to care about the killing of unarmed
civilians
any time you see uh someone with blm in
their in their their twitter profile
um and they're lamenting the the the
death of dante wright or george floyd or
anyone else
search their name and then the name
ashley babbitt
and see what they had to say about her
because i will tell you right now it's
either
nothing or they were celebrating it
aside from babbitt the names of the
other white people killed by police
are known only to their families and
friends
not one protest has been staged on their
behalf
not one riot has broken out not one
building burned
burned in their honor not one pair of
shoes looted from a foot locker
you know it's a curious thing that those
who are still overwhelmed by the pain of
george floyd's death a year later they
haven't gotten over it
there's over what they didn't know him
they know anything about him they're
overwhelmed by the pain
it's curious they can be so selective in
that pain
was floyd more deserving of mourning was
dante wright more deserving of mourning
than any average white person killed by
the cops
now the excuse most commonly given for
this disparity in coverage and outrage
is that
while black people are killed by police
less often
when you account for population
disparities they are still more likely
to be killed by police and i've
addressed this claim many times
now even if this statistic needed no
qualification
how does that explain or justify the
fact that people who protest alleged
police brutality
never protest alleged police brutality
against white people
the fact that it happens proportionally
less often
what that means that it's not an outrage
it's not a tragedy
the flag the fact that black people are
more likely to be killed by police means
that george floyd's death warrants a
year of public wailing in mourning
and the death of a white man warrants no
public wailing or mourning
at all okay because the proportionality
of outrage
is is there's zero percent you want to
talk about percentages
you always say there's there's a smaller
percentage of white people killed by
cops
okay but the percentage of outrage
over those killings is zero zero percent
it appears that the black lives matter
crowd really does
believe that only black lives matter
or at least that they matter quite a bit
more than white lives
what other conclusion could one draw
now as it happens the statistics cited
earlier does require qualification yes a
black person is more
likely to be killed by police but a
black person is also more likely to
commit
violent crime if we're talking about
proportionality we have to look at the
whole picture
the whole picture even after just a
glance
severely complicates the simplified
racial narrative that you hear from the
blm set
but again this is beside the present
point
that doesn't even matter for the point
that i'm making here
no statistic can explain why the
emotional reaction from the so-called
anti-fascists
should be so selective why they should
remain sitting on their hands
while white people are shot dead waiting
until someone with a darker skin tone
suffers that same fate
real moral outrage doesn't work like
that
and that's how we know that none of the
outrage we're seeing
is real none of it is real
it is all performance it is all fake
it is ideological
[Music]
really when it comes down to it and we
should always remember that especially
in the months ahead because there's
going to be a lot more of this
a lot more listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated